good to see the head coach of the Los
Angeles Rams Shaun McVeigh are you doing
coach doing great thanks for having me
rich that's a good lineup you got today
man I feel special being part of this
look I got to tell you you came on a
good day but I know we were talking
about it coming back from the combine
where and also at the Super Bowl where
we where we first crossed pads about you
haven't you come in here so I appreciate
you you doing that how has the first few
months of you taking this gig been for
you well it's been great everybody asks
they say how's it going I said we're
still undefeated asked me week six I
like to go it's uh it's been great you
know I think the thing that you feel so
fortunate about rich is you get a chance
to be around a bunch of other great
coaches it kind of helped out you know
you look at being able to have a wage
Phillips on our staff you know the
advice that he's able to give me with
some of the things that he's gone
through with all the experiences that
he's had you get some other great
leaders in place with the John fossil
who was an interim role last year but
what a great leader he is that special
teams and really of the team in general
and a lot of other coaches that I could
go on and on about but it's been a great
offseason program I think we got what we
want accomplished and you know really
ready for a little bit of a break and
then ready to go at it when we get back
to Irvine for camp before we get to that
though Steve when I flew back from the
combine you were on that flight coach
okay and next you sat next to Jack Del
Rio I did the two of you guys and you
guys were like talking each other's ear
off though fly home at may I ask cuz I
could not hear ya I don't want to pry
but I'll say what it was I he tried me
out man I'm just trying to get some rest
on the way back from the combine and he
was great you know I had met him a
couple times before and we had some
common friends and we were really I was
just kind of picking his brain and he
was so what about share what about you
know just you know the whole thing as
far as everything that this position
entails and you know things from when
you've got 90 guys on the roster we're
building and developing those
relationships is so important how do you
find a way to connect with all those
guys when you don't know a lot of them
you know how do you deal with different
circumstances and situations I mean he
was asking questions to that kind of
forced you to think through some things
like you know you think you're prepared
but until you really go through it and
experience the day-to-day grind which we
know the real adversity comes when you
go through the season you're playing
games but a lot of the advice that he
was able to give me on that flight were
things that were ended up being really
helpful you know over the last few
months right yeah I'm ready for
practices schedules things of that
nature
yeah I mean something as simple as where
it just kind of reiterates a lot of your
core beliefs but you know empowering
those players when you've got the right
guys that you can rely on their opinions
when you've got a Steve Smith or for us
you know the Andrew Whitworth of the
world the Ogletree is there and Donald's
where you can really value their
opinions and and then they have some
ownership and kind of some of the things
that you're doing and then that
accountability is kind of both coach and
player driven I mean what do you think
about when you hear that Steve but
there's always a there's always a
perspective when a new coach comes in he
always brings in the guys that he's more
comfortable with them he feels that he
can trust and so hearing that it
reinforces that but also is good to hear
I think he's going to have a lot of good
success over the long haul because he's
young enough he can relate and also he's
he's creating a culture that guys can
respect and Trust without using the
trust me
so I think that's good yeah I mean here
and I think he's also a guy that's going
to probably be working out with the guys
too you know since he did yeah I mean
I'd shirts medium you are wearing a very
nice polo shirt that does look like it
is from the hockey league collection I
got to be honest with you it's a yeah
showing it oh hey that's a I'll take
that as a compliment rich now but have
you gotten into the workout room which
we know what we try to stay active a
little bit you know just to get out
throw the guys it's actually
embarrassing you like to think you're
still an athlete I was out there running
some sprints you know probably a month
and a half ago and I actually pulled my
quad so it's like I'll let me hold you
put me on the album Amy OH with just
crush me with I'll be blind would have
fired me how to crush them man feel that
B oh yeah
you don't realize how much you move
around at practice you go yeah my joy
wow that's good to hear it's not as easy
as you draw it up well exactly right so
but I mean on a second hold on a second
hold on a second you've got one of Miami
of Ohio finest wide receivers sitting
right here it's not as if you've never
played
position I thought I was an athlete
still then you get out there and you
can't you got to make sure that you
stretch before I didn't get out there
and start running with the guys and not
the same I'm getting old house mmm he
saw Cooper Cup out there and he was like
he can do it now now I know I saw last
night I've got I've got John McVay and
Steve Smith here together in the Rich
Eisen show studio I saw last night on
your Twitter feed you're going back and
forth with individuals what are that it
wasn't like a it wasn't an argument it
was never because I'm an analyst and I
want people to see and respect when I
give my opinion on football that I'm not
going to be just one of those guys it
just says all these guys not very good
or disguise the world but I loved Kubek
up all the film that I watched on them
there's a lot of receivers in the draft
and the later rounds and went undrafted
that I think are going to be stellar
athletes ten plus years of contributing
that I don't think all of the first or
second round guys are wide receivers are
going to outlast some of the guys in the
later rounds what you see at a Cooper
Cup that you yeah and I saw that you
wanted you and less needing the whole
crew over there said let's go get it
well a lot of the same things I mean you
look at the production that he had at
the collegiate level whether you know
and really he played against a lot of
big-time players that have had success
in this league you go back to the
Washington tape a few years back his
sophomore year when he's going against
players like butta Baker Marcus Peters
guys like that is that whole secondary
got drift exactly not on Sidney Gentiles
you have a lot of numbers on that
secretary that got drafted in Pro Bowl
that's exactly right and then when they
play against Oregon so you know he
showed up week in and week out and he's
one of the more mature polished college
receivers that you know I've ever
evaluated coming out he's got a plan his
ability to articulate what's going on I
mean you know we had a little bit of
exposure with Peyton Manning this
offseason and you know he had some
interaction with him at his camp over
the last handful years and you know
Peyton enjoyed throwing to him and I
mean that's that says a lot worse now
I'm throwing the cup I know where he's
going to be and doing different things
like that but he's been an impressive
kid just with the way that he's handled
himself where he's you know he's a pro
as a rookie
what do you mean Tatum adding had
interaction with him you brought him in
so well so we had you know we crossed
paths he's done some different things
and you know just a little bit
interaction just you know through
some of the different connections that
he has with people in our building and
he was just mentioning that at his
passing camp over the last handful of
years Cooper's been a participant in you
know when they're throwing routes on air
and things like de says I'm throwing a
cup so Eli you stay away from him okay
because well you know when you mentioned
Peyton Manning's name and you know he
was mentioned maybe after his Dallas
Denver days maybe to come here to Los
Angeles yeah now you've got obvious but
that that's makes people in this town
stop in their tracks but well that has
nothing we do one reason why he was in a
row so when we signed Kayvon Webster you
know because he was doing a bunch of
different things we're just kind of
getting a feel and getting some exposure
to different things around the league
and when we signed Kayvon Webster who
was a former teammate is in Denver he
put it on his snapchat so that's how
everybody knew that Payton was out
visiting but uh you know really it was
more than anything just a great example
and and you know for me mean guys like
Peyton Steve you know guys that have
played this game at a high at the
highest level and then they you know
their ability to articulate and
communicate you know from their
perspective is a great value for fir
coach that rams coach Sean McVeigh here
in the Rich Eisen show studio you said
that Tavon Austin I saw recently a
comment that you're going to feature him
that he's going to be featured in this
offense in a manner that we haven't not
perhaps seen before there are two cities
of two different fan bases who have
heard that statement before what makes
you think that this could be different
for fans to see what you've got cooked
up for tavon well I think that's the
plan you know because really for us
coming in as a new staff you evaluate
what you see on tape and what you see is
a dynamic playmaker with the ball in his
hands and you know I think the challenge
for him and really for all of us is is
to figure out let's continue to develop
being a more complete receiver where
we've got a short and intermediate a
down the field route tree and you know
we'll utilize him and the way that we
feel like is best for his skill set and
really for our offense and for our team
as a whole and one of the things that
was tough is thought he did a great job
controlling what he can control but he
had a wrist injury that you know the
only time we really saw him on the field
contributing or you know competing was
before he had that surgery at the
voluntary minicamp he did a nice job
showed some intriguing things but we've
got some guys that offer
some depth in that room and and tavon
we're expecting them to be a big part of
it and we're looking forward to seeing
how he does in camp have you ever had
interaction with him Steve yeah uh I'll
talk to him I'll talk to him I love him
I think life you do oh yeah he he has
all the grit he has the desire um you
know he's from Baltimore yeah and I you
know I spoke to him actually when I was
in Baltimore he was and they were in st.
Louis so I talked to him he was very
frustrated with the over zinging which
is easily can be seen easily because of
the lack of opportunities but I mean
he's done a great job when I was with
the Panthers he made a big play on us
thank goodness somebody was holding so
that they you know that I worked out so
negate it but I mean every time he gets
the ball he's a playmaker and you know
he's part of little people I loved ah I
got it
yeah well Sean McVeigh is here in studio
I'd like to take a break come back talk
a little bit more about your background
you've got some serious football DNA
within you sir and and then obviously
the the quarterback Jared Goff and
whether you can whisper in his ear in
the same manner that you've whispered
another quarterbacks ears and had them
succeed Sean McVeigh is here in the Rich
Eisen show studio so is Steve Smith
Ice Cube and Amy trask making their way
here in our number three talked some
hoops and some Raiders football with
them when they join us that's all still
to come here on the show
all right Sean McVeigh here let's show
what you talking about the guns
I mean seriously where do you live
nearby the practice facility and
Counting I'm about 20 minutes about 20
minutes from the facility okay
how does long I think it's it's this hot
this is really the shirt makes you look
better than what it is I'm not in the
shape that I'd like to be in so how does
it tight shirt how does Beltway traffic
compared to Los Angeles traffic you know
what they're both tough fortunately the
guns that we're commuting you know not
having to hit too bad a traffic so okay
so you're oh you're trying to get up
early so we can avoid it and and we've
been lucky in that regard but sometimes
when you come home a little bit earlier
than you know you're stuck on that 1:10
for a while to the 110 sucks so you've
learned to rough life yeah okay you're
learning the claim I'm learning it but
but I'm loving it I didn't realize how
spread out LA was until you get out here
just a quick story and I've said this on
the air and I don't we're flying back in
that plane you're sitting on the right
side of the plane I'm on the left side
of the plane
the right side of the plane is where you
could see the 405 going north which is
going to be what I had to deal with as
soon as I got on the flight home and
when I landed so I turn to you and I'm
like just check out see what the traffic
is on the 405 for me and you didn't know
a little didn't record it with our robot
was embarrassing no it's not that much
of a clueless going on other than with
football now you know though yeah now
you're a little bit
Tomic say here in studio with Steve
Smith who's been kind enough to stick
around for a whole show which I love as
Cuba and Amy Trask are making their way
for our number three here on the show so
if I am not mistaken Sean your
grandfather the draft room in San
Francisco is named after him how about
that yeah just this past year you know
or within the last year they named it
the John McVay draft room so that's a
pretty cool deal for him and you know
the contributions that he made to that
organization well things like the
drafting of say people like Joe Montana
Jerry Rice correct
no I'm mistaken we've all got a lot of
that you know with with coach Walsh and
you know that's the out there from right
from the beginning honestly Wow well you
have five rings thanks appreciate those
well in your in your you just nobody
said I know he's dumping his Chester out
of my grandpa well yes the fandom that
you enjoyed being a 49er fan was born
out of a lot of the fruits of your
grandfather's labored do you do you
remember anything but like what's your
first football memory you know I was I
was too young to appreciate you know the
early years where they were winning but
you know I can remember when they they
actually were in the same division as
the Falcons you know a handful years ago
I remember when they come out with Steve
and when Jerry was there and you know
I'd sit on the bus with Jesse Sapolu and
Dexter Carter's returning kicks so that
was that was a cool deal to be able to
be around that and I don't think you
really realized how much you kind of
absorb and appreciate it until you're
able to look back on it and then realize
because you just you don't know any
better you think that's kind of a norm
and then you realize what a great at
unique experience that was to be able to
be exposed to that at such an early age
Oh big expectations of you now is there
no from here all the way up there that's
it so that's your first memories riding
the bus with the 49ers yeah no you know
and I remember you know what we're
talking about the secret well yeah and
where you team yeah mooch oh my
absolutely
so tell me something that can help me
make much feel older than he really is
what did woody got for me how old were
you on the Mariucci buses that's about
eight
well I was out all tonight I wasn't that
young I was probably more like you know
12 13 no no you said eight and we're
going to stick with date cuz well you
all know Buffy for AJ Stokes
oh yeah oh yeah eight was still cozy for
because I was I make you feel that was
born in 86 that's when I graduated high
school but that's okay so no but let's
make much field as old as possible so in
all seriousness though like it's
interesting because Mariucci got his
first gig through John Robinson right
right here in Los Angeles with the Rams
and years later obviously we could go to
so many different ways with this whole
sort of football Kevin Bacon 6° thing
but you know now here's later you're
riding a bus while he is a head coach
the 49ers now you're the head coaches of
law Los Angeles Rams wild have you
stopped at any moment to just say what
how the heck did this happen now you
know the I would say the main thing rich
is what you're able to appreciate is the
people that have been you know so
invested in helping me even get to this
opportunity and it doesn't happen
without being around great people and it
really starts with getting the
opportunity to get into this league at
an early age because of my grandfather's
influence working under Jon Gruden Jay
Gruden working with Mike Shanahan I mean
I've been very fortunate Bruce Allen a
lot of great people that have invested
in you know the timing has worked out
really in a in a very fortunate manner
to be sitting here have you been told
you sound
Gruden and ask I've heard that quite
often I'll take it as a compliment
though cuz you know he was one of my
biggest mentors and John yeah Jay Mohr
you know both of them are as influential
as anybody that I've been around in the
coaching profession but you know what I
can appreciate what John is when you get
into this business
he truly taught me to see the game from
a 22-man perspective and then the
ability to connect with guys and
understand you know you know from an
above the next standpoint how to connect
with the players but then also motivate
them I mean he's one of the best I've
been around but John also I don't
believe really ever found a quarterback
that he wanted to attach himself to that
guy that happens and sit there for 10-15
years that really is not it it's some
good stuff because I don't
no I'm not set no I'm not saying that
when he attached himself to a hip it was
not magical at times but if I'm not
mistaken you never really like found
somebody certainly not a young guy that
he was a surgeon he was always sort of a
young guy he did a lot older guys but
never got it and Brad Johnson was super
bowl with him grow old together and you
know Raider fans like say cube would
point out that Gannon should have been
in that Super Bowl yeah I go it's not
for a certain rule that got opted out
somewhere you'd have a lot of people
that would talk about I'm sure Sean
McVeigh here in studio so what it will
it be like when you go well when
Washington comes out here week two I see
the guys who you have been coaching for
all those years across the way in the
Coliseum
ya know how to be a unique experience
and you know a lot of people that were
instrumental and helping me get to this
point you know with Jay Gruden and what
he's been to me and a lot of those other
coaches I look at you know being able to
work with Bill Callahan guys like that
and then and then the players you know
some really special people that are
special men but they're also great
players and you don't get an opportunity
to move up in the coaching ranks if you
don't work with great players and that's
one of the things you appreciate is that
we around a lot of those in Washington
and it's going to be a great challenge
and we've got some guys we feel good
about here in LA but I can't wait it's
going to be a special day and really
looking forward to that well I haven't
you know this is no longer your business
but I'm asking it to you anyway okay
how's that that is an open offer I got
remembers the first week of the job
talking about this no no why why have it
the Redskins bought all the way in on
Kirk Cousins well do you think I think
they have and you know I think there's
well I think so I think there's a lot of
different things that are involved in it
and I'm gonna I'm gonna stop right there
you'll get a kick out of this rich
because entering so the first so after I
get this job you know we go back and
kind of do a couple things with the
Washington media that have been good to
me and you start talking about Kirk
Cousins and they ask you about the
contract situation how you feel about
them and you know so I go on and be a
very complimentary of Kirk and the nice
things that you think and Kevin dumb off
calls me says you know that's going to
be tampering you can't do that anymore I
said okay sorry about that the team
president called you up now he was great
about
he called me a let's let's take it easy
on the on the positivity on querque oh
let's just talk about our players move
for us that's a good that's a good point
I and I understand that and I will move
off this in just one one one more second
I will but I won't I don't know I know
because we're seeing we just saw you
know obviously Derek cars in a different
situation and you hope to be in the
situation with Jared dog obviously was
fraying but to be in this situation
right exactly where people are getting
paid yeah people are getting paid in
some people who haven't won Super Bowls
or gone and won a playoff game right are
getting paid and Kirk Cousins has gotten
this team to the playoffs I mean this
will happen and yet it's just a
year-to-year situation why do you can
you just put shed any light on why you
think that well I think you just talk
about the quarterback position and the
importance that it has overall you know
when you've got a guy you believe in you
know you got a chance in every single
game and I think that's why you see the
amount of money that's allocated to that
specific position because those guys you
know end up being the difference and
winning losing games and when you have
the ball in your hands every snap
offensively you have the opportunity to
make a lot of plays and be the
difference in the outcome and when
you've got a guy that you believe in and
that's the right guy then you make those
decisions
yeah well long term he's getting paid
it's just year-to-year I mean he's
getting I mean you look at compared to
what Derek Carr is getting paid he's
he's he's right there right what what
they're doing is basically they're they
are dating and they're waiting for a
prettier girl we're better assets to
work so they could commit that's what
they're doing he can't say it there's
two things here oh that's a funny things
I know in life mm-hmm or shoes and
quarterbacks why or cyou says the other
thing I just love more shoes
speaking of shoes okay fresh it's so
fresh squeezed and how is that how you
like your quarterbacks - I mean oh ok
freshly Sun appropriate no no no I'm
just trying to find what the analogies
would be I just know those two things
and and I know as a quarterback and I'm
see what they're doing they're not
paying them and they're not paying them
for reason Nate and I I don't believe as
a former player and a wire receiver
they pay you when they believe in you
and when you are forced to pay somebody
year-to-year they're saying we like you
until we get a better opportunity or
we're forced to right and they're
they're getting to that point where they
have to have to make a decision I think
they are trying to figure out sure we
should not to Ignacio in our show and
they're not well again they are paying
him either just not getting him long but
are forced to pay him they have to pay
him cuz there's no one better right now
there's no better options but until some
better options comes they're either
gonna pay them long term we're gonna
move on he's such a good dude - I mean
like crazy
he's aces I mean that's the type of face
of the franchise
you want if I guess they're not
committing to let me ask you this Steve
from your perspective as a receiver yes
what are the things that separate the
great ones in your mind the great
quarterbacks well a consistent throw um
being able to anchor and lead a meeting
be able to pay attention and have an
open dialogue um you know to have an
argument yeah and it not be personal
because of understanding that the
argument isn't based on I think I know
more it's this is our job this is how we
feed our family brands how we pay for
college for our children this affects
everything and so when it affects
everything you are thinking about things
a lot different things all you didn't do
this okay
and live for another day because
eventually if it doesn't go your way and
it doesn't work for everybody what goes
first player then coach and then when
the news coach comes in he gets rid of
other players and the new coach brings
in the players that he feels can help
implement and you know articulate what
his message and what the team philosophy
is that's why you brought in new players
that's the difference between a good and
a great quarterback and your estimation
I mean there's a lot of things that go
on beyond works behind the scenes well I
think a good player is able to hand a
great quarterback is able to handle
circumstances and criticism and be able
to move on
be able to let it go and still be
effective in his job I take I mean
really you know you talk about what made
him such a great player riches you know
to me what you just described to is a
great competitor you know there's a
level of urgency and an intrinsic
motivation that the great ones have
whether it be a quarterback or a
receiver where hey this is business
we're trying to be the best that we can
be this isn't personal this is about
producing and doing the things necessary
to win football games and us all have
success together and I agree worry less
about being your friend and more about
doing our job I want to be afraid
because we could be friends we suck then
we're now we're just two good friends at
all different teams or on the floor hey
not a simple way of putting it yeah well
but it's the truth yeah you know I mean
it's a business and it is but these are
made if production isn't there yes but
how many quarterbacks have that thick
skin
oh they're handled differently I get
that well I mean every time I hear again
and it's a fun conversation we always
have on game day morning you know when
there is a conversation about whether a
quarterback is performing up to snuff or
not SAP when you was sitting there would
always be like you know look defensive
linemen defensive players if we're not
pulling our weight they're going to get
somebody and we're going to crate
they're going to bring two guys and
they're going to draft another guy
they're going to bring three guys in and
I've got to deal with it right and
Marshall would be the same thing but
running back same thing here and Urban's
like same thing here and then all of a
sudden everybody would just start
staring a hole through Kurt and mooch
because mooch is the coach yeah and the
quarterback and they're like why are you
guys so coddled why you guys why don't
you guys like competition as not they
hold the keys that came and they impact
the whole structure of the organization
if you if you pick the wrong quarterback
talking about the Washington Redskins
look at the infrastructure and look at
what has transcended through them
picking rg3 it's been musical chairs and
things have changed dramatically and we
I'll never forget and then we'll take a
break because I want to talk about your
quarterback but I'll never forget
sitting in the on the draft set that
night and Radio City Music Hall
rg3 was pick second in
went down the street and attended the
lot what is a live showing of 30 rock
right Brockman is nobody did that not
yes yes great I ran into Kim Kardashian
yeah and then there was a whole hoo-ha
over that because she you know went up
to him and that was that was a big TMZ
moment yeah he was already out the gate
out the door and then later on um the
next night Kirk Cousins is draft in the
third round and I looked at Mayock and
I'm like what gives with that and and
nobody really had an answer and I think
you know one person wanted him the other
person did and the one person who only
had to tell you had to be in the meeting
I could tell you that that's what
transpired right and the one person that
wanted him is now an advisor for his son
up in San Francisco where your
grandfather has his name on the draft
room that's right
and rg3 is I don't know where he is
today at ATC chillin at the crib we're
back in 60 seconds with John McVay of
the oh yeah we're we're going to come
learning now we are going to download
you know Sean McVeigh of the ranch will
come back talk jag off with Steve Smith
in a moment
I know we're having good conversations
with people in studio like Sean McVeigh
the head coach the Los Angeles Rams and
Steve Smith from the NFL Network when we
continue the conversation in the
60-second break what were you saying
about your philosophy on quarterbacking
in the 21st century well I think in
general you know you look back to some
of the influences you've had and I think
about what my grandfather told me coach
Walsh used to always say is that it's
the most difficult position all sports
and our job as a coaching staff is to
figure out a way to make the most
difficult position as simple as we can
and really being in a situation in
Washington as a coordinator the last
handful years where you're calling plays
you've got to be mindful when you put
together a game plan all right the first
thing that you have to have in mind is
is the quarterback are these plays
conducive to his strengths and then you
want to obviously get your playmakers
involved when you've got a guy like
Steve you got to get him involved early
in the game and get him going but it
starts with a quarterback because
everything else kind of goes into it but
you got to make sure that you're doing
the things that are going to be
conducive to that player skillset and
that's why I think there is so much
emphasis placed on it and it's why like
you look at when you've got those guys
you hold on to them you pay them and and
and then you feel like you've got an
answer for that position for a long time
to come you give yourself a chance to
compete for championships so when you
guys do the draft you know I think of
the Cleveland Browns when they got a Tim
Couch and he was in that office maybe
like it was a 20 play playbook fair well
you guys do your research how honest are
those coaches with you guys interview
interview the coaches and understand the
system in which they're playing are they
you know kind of guessing you guys you
know saying like oh this guy can learn
in any as a learner's deficiency or he's
never really been pushed to learn a real
NFL style playbook where's you know 100
Shelton plays is just literally you know
50 plays in 50 other positions and
different person else yeah what goes on
that's a great question Steve because I
think the first thing that makes it
difficult when you're just evaluating
specifically the quarterback position is
you look at the emphasis that's placed
on the spread systems and they've been
the ones that have had a lot of success
collegiate Lee so that's what you're
going to do and the width of the hashes
changes the way that you attack
people as well but you do do a lot of
emphasis on some of the gist the mental
testing you know they've got different
types of tests where you kind of project
the guy's ability to learn you don't
want to necessarily punish a guy for not
having played underneath the center
being exposed to pure progression
concepts different things like that so
now you know with the way that the
college game has evolved a little bit it
is a little bit easier to project some
of those quarterbacks that are doing the
things that you can see all right I'm
operating under center I'm working a
play action a movement game three five
and seven step drops I'm playing out of
the gun on third down and doing a couple
little different things so a lot of it
is based on your projections evaluating
a guy's ability to throw the football
and then the interview process is really
really important where you kind of test
the guy and you're more analyzing their
ability to learn and retain in a short
amount of time so it does make it
difficult but you but the coaches are
always going to be pretty positive you
know for the most part so the cause
would be positive about a guy who is
inefficient of retaining information
well I think I think it's I think it's a
it's a healthy dynamic because they has
a contribution to their organ today to
Legion University you know so that's a
tough role of that by the way healthy
dynamic would be a great name Brockman
put that down for a fantasy football
team name healthy dynamic that's a new
that's a new one for me too Alexi gave
me a TC a give you healthy Dane I like
like Sean McVeigh it's called a
symbiotic relationship Steve Smith also
sitting here so what are Jared Goff
strengths based on everything we've just
known it's talked about know when you
look at it and you watch the tape and
you evaluate some of the things that he
was doing even just coming out of cow
the first thing that you look at just
from a physical standpoint with the
quarterback is he a natural thrower of
the football he's a natural throw the
football you can make the short the
intermediate the long throws stands tall
in the pocket when things condense
around him I think he's got a nice
natural feel and a movement and the
thing that you really like is he took
some shots last year and he's a tough
player he's going to keep his eyes down
the field he's not going to watch the
rush so when you flip on the tape those
were the things that you were excited
about when you flipped that New Orleans
game on last year he did a lot of good
things he did down and in in a very
difficult spot to do a lot of good
things in for if I'm not mistaken that
was
first road start I might be off on that
hunt but it was one of his birthday and
then it was in normal baby girl you
would know better obviously having
watched all his tape but it was I'll
tell you what though you watch him he's
making zero checks versus a zero
pressure you know he gets to tighten in
a protection set so he's able to make a
throw yet stave on Austin on a corner
out from the three spot I mean he did a
lot of things where he's naturally
moving he finds Kendricks for a
touchdown I mean he did some things that
you're like you know that that's
exciting to see and now it's our job as
a coaching staff to help him
consistently find his rhythm get
comfortable with what he's comfortable
with because so what what is he
comfortable with based on what fans and
the Rams might not have seen based on
all team you know that's something that
we're continued to evaluate because I
think the thing especially with that
position in the spring you know I
thought he did a nice job progressing
each day throughout the offseason
program where you get really too many
camps in your Tenno TAS and I thought he
handled the above the neck information
got in and out of the huddle did a
really nice job commanding that and then
with the drop back game he does a good
job you know he's got a good feel and
it's just figuring out a way to be
consistent kind of really become an
extension of the coaching staff and when
you do that then you feel really good
and then we have different things that
we want to emphasize offensively but
certainly we're going to put a premium
on what our guys end up getting really
good at you know it's the same thing in
the running game you know you've got a
couple concepts that you want to carry
but when you've got a dynamic player
like Todd Gurley you're going to adjust
to what he does best you know certain
guys run certain schemes a certain way
bantam this year I mean it's gonna be
because I'm playing some football
nowadays wait are you in program is a
projection we as a coaching staff feel
very good about Todd Gurley Steve okay
because I'm I'm a 49ers fan I can't
really uh I don't tech I like I like me
but I don't really want to draft him you
know but I mean is this gonna hurt my my
draft if I drop them because Jeff Fisher
screwed it up so I'm just you know
excited about Todd okay I like to hear
that I love the wide receivers but I
want to make sure this is all about me
right if there is an iron Smith yes
there is ah did you think when you woke
up today Sean McVeigh be have your brain
picked for fantasy football advice by
Steve Smith I did
well I actually when we walked in and I
see Steve on the scent I said oh this is
good man I had never met Steve I've
always admired his game in the way that
he's competed from afar so this is this
is fun for me
okay well so is that an invitation to
come to a training camp and I literally
here because I'm I'm busy maybe
traveling but absolutely yeah okay I
think no if I'm not going to door now
you man now you won't get that you're
welcome man breaking news Steve Smith
announces come back with lrn yeah I like
you now I like the way you're hired
that's what I heard
I will be I may have a diction with me
as he allow absolutely stay cool fingers
me yeah this my son I mean your your
your he's pretty cool yeah well I just
also felt a that he's no he introduced
today I kind of felt stupid where I'm
like okay so Jared Goff I think that was
his first career start on the road and
then I should have just turned to you
because have you watched every stop
oh yeah and you know that was how many
times have you watched every snap well
you know you watch you watch all the
snaps even going into the interview
process you try to at least have a feel
because part of the interview is when
you're sitting there with Kevin dumb off
less needed Tony Pass stores you're
going to talk about the personnel in
place yes you know so so that may be
part of primping for the interview is
being able to articulate your thoughts
on the offense defense and special teams
structure that they have in place and
then how the vision that you would want
to have with you and your coaching staff
would project you know moving into free
agency in the draft so should we have
assumed it you wouldn't have taken this
job mmm if you did not think Jared golf
was a viable quarterback well I think I
think anytime well let's put it this way
this is a great opportunity to be one of
32 so you know just is always something
that you strive to do but you know that
when you've got a guy that you think
projects as somebody that gives you a
chance you feel good about it because if
you don't have that guy it's tough
sledding and that was definitely
something that when you're watching that
you see the characteristics and the
trade show up and that's why I actually
rich it you get a chance to spend some
time with Jared in the interview
yeah when I went interviewed I was
talking to him about you know I'd be
interested to see how he took last year
obviously things didn't go the way that
we wanted them to go and we sat down we
watched some tape where I spent a couple
hours
with him at part of the first interview
and that was instrumental and feeling
good about it and really you know you're
part of it is you're selling yourself to
him to here's some of the things we've
done here's where you think it would
project and it helped me really
appreciate that one thing that I really
liked about him rich is when you sit
down with them a lot of times when
things don't go your way you have a
tendency to blame other people all he
did was take accountability never went
the easy way out and said you know I'm
challenging the right way to respond and
your knew as opposed to making excuses
for why it didn't go the way we wanted
to yes so that's my life so if you
brought some oh well you know he what he
was accountable and that's what I can
appreciate he one complaint one making
excuses he was just looking at what he
can do to get better and I didn't sense
a guy that his confidence was was shaken
at all from not you know doing some of
the things that you know that we wanted
to accomplish in year one and that's
what you like about him he's motivated
in the right way where he's still got
some swag and some confidence like I
believe I I know that I'm capable of
being a good player in this league and
that's what you like good to have you
here this doors open to any time I know
you're busy got that but I mean we're
local you know I'm saying come on back
it is sometimes a we caught it we could
it was a good day without any traffic
that's the cold that's the 405 you came
down right like this 405 good to see you
coach thanks a dash on McVeigh of the
Rams is here Steve Smith hanging out
with us all the rest of the show is well
IceCube and also Amy Trask at the big
three and our Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that please download our app there's
lots of fun things there other than just
more of the videos you just saw you can
call us from the app you can email us
from the app just download it trust me
you'll enjoy